they want to go out and they want to
touch they want to vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
suppression balls
yesterday we had three big ones really
big
suppression balls don't give me the
umbrella i'm
soaking wet already they put numbers you
know they're called suppression
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly
so you say to your wife or you say to
your husband darling let's go out to
dinner and then we'll come back we love
our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost
suppression balls
suppression balls in the name of jesus
from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
they're coming here from africa
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
winning winning
by david jones is his running mate the
most liberal senator in america
kamala
senator kamala harris
democrat kamala
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer their common fear
if you love someone who has
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
hey little prickles now that your uh
your
hero is there are you gonna sit there in
your little kimono
and wear your little hat rice because
it's going to be called no free speech
red chinese communist speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs
after all you're going to love this too
they're going to make a bomb and i hope
they drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork you but you
can't have pork
but you can't have pork just stick that
microphone right up your ass
this is highly triggered this is an
extremely triggered individual
the men and women of the united states
space force
will be known as guardians
oh no
no it can't be
from our president a man who is actually
in space
right now space farce
guardians operating in a vacuum space is
a warfighting domain
when it comes to the outer reaches of
space you are that strength
if you rise on the wings of the dawn if
you settle
on the far side of the sea even if you
go
up to the heavens what the hell
that there his hand will guide you
and his right hand will hold you fast to
defend america
and defend our freedom from space space
guardians god bless our guardians
guardians
guardians they didn't bother to
interview a single
witness just like you they don't want to
know the truth
well you probably know the truth okay so
so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
i'd say that poll book is off by over a
hundred thousand
that poll books why don't you look at
the registered voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
all right welcome everybody there is
only so much time for song parodies but
uh we actually
are um i i guess arguably today
we have the biggest conservative event
of the year right behind a riotous
insurrection
at the capitol on january 6th it is cpac
organized by the american conservative
union
it is the conservative political action
conference 2021
it is not remote it is not socially
distance
it is not mask required it is just a
conference as if nothing was going on
whatsoever
um it's days and days of this stuff my
plan as i told you guys before
is just to cover the two what i think
are going to be the two most watched
elements
uh kimberly guilfoyle will be
introducing her partner
donald trump jr in about 45 minutes and
we're going to watch that
tomorrow i don't plan to do any
streaming in fact i
i may be quite ill tomorrow i did get my
second vaccine dose today
i got quite febrile uh last time so i'm
planning on nothing tomorrow but then
on uh sunday i do plan to broadcast
the a final event the main event donald
trump
former president and he will um
he will possibly be announcing that he
is running in 2024. we don't know
but there is the rumor that donald trump
may announce during his speech on
sunday which will be in the three
o'clock hour eastern
he may be announcing his candidacy for
2024
so we are going to be looking at all of
it
very very strongly and we are standing
by
just as a little preview of what you
might expect from kimberly guilfoyle
this was her at the republican national
convention some of you may remember this
it was
it was pretty pretty disturbing take a
look ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for freedom and liberty
and the american dream the best
is yet to come
so really really inspirational and a lot
of uh
a lot of a lot of young girls learned
they too
could do something after seeing that
speech although
run for president was not exactly the
message they came away with so
that is more of what we are expecting
a little bit later today okay a few
super chats
daniel from california says my
girlfriend wants to know if you have
ever tried boba
milk tea or if you have a frequent sweet
drink
also can you un-shadow ban me from the
phone lines
um we can't really ban people from the
phone lines
i have had a boba milk tea yes i love
the tapioca balls
i also uh don't mind the uh lychee
lychee can be nice doug says did i wait
the 12 weeks supposedly effective no
i i first of all i got the moderna
vaccine there is this idea that's being
tested with the pfizer vaccine that if
you spread out the two doses you it may
have even higher
uh effectiveness but that is not fda
approved and that is not the vaccine i
got so i did what the fda said which is
dose one 28 days ago
dose two today and in fact let's see if
i'm developing a fever i do have an
infrared
thermometer here let's just see together
where we are
if i do develop a fever this is like at
the dentist i'll end the stream so that
nobody gets sick
97 7 very strong very very strong right
now
so the stream will continue we will do
periodic checks and if it were right to
develop a fever
we will uh we will exit the stream
tristan macappen did i get madonna yes
yes i got moderna i showed up and they
said to me
sir second dose is that way and i said
um i said to my girlfriend why are you
calling me surry you're not melania
that's a weird thing to say
okay um let's see where where do i even
start today
um we can look at some of the most
insane moments so far today i read that
ted cruz had
almost like a psychotic break earlier
today during his presentation at cpac
i also have a new voicemail character to
introduce to you like
it's an actual new caller we've moved on
past troy york his voicemails have
become
so predictable and pedantic that we're
sort of moving on unless the dynamic
changes
yesterday i introduced a new character
to you guys who we i think are calling
the manic moderate he wasn't actually
that extreme politically
he was just seemed to be having a manic
episode so
yesterday was the manic moderate today i
have a voicemail i've just labeled it as
outrageous i didn't even know
how to characterize it beyond that
so at some point we can get to that
um i also have
one unban request that i could do by
popular demand
i do now gavel in when we uh when we
when we call to order a a court
of twitch unban requests so we could do
that
um okay yeah let's do it let's look at
unban
requests okay
uh i am officially calling to order the
court of unbans
there we go this is a user named gonzalo
gonzalo's participation on my twitch
channel
has been as follows david pakman why do
you support the cia puppets who tried to
kill maduro
15 seconds later david pakman why do you
support the cia puppets who tried to
kill maduro
then
hassan vietnam is the best example david
vietnam is the best example
david vietnam is the best example david
you and joe biden are pure cucks
he was then banned and then his unbanned
request
is f off [ __ ] and [ __ ] has an accent
over the second o which i've not seen
before
um okay i am officially going to be
denying that unban request
and that is going to be a permanent ban
deny
send deny decision uh just no
it's just that's just an obvious no i
don't even need to get help from the uh
from the audience for that one okay so
that is it as far as
unban requests today and we will
continue monitoring and see if any
others
uh come forward will i open the phone
lines today
yes if we get to a hundred website
members and twitch subscribers
okay i'm going to hold fast on it we
have a goal
that goal is 100. as far as twitch goes
we've already got three
thanks to oh thanks to astrolycos
gifting three that's it
all right very good that puts us at
three and uh of course
the website is fully enabled and ready
for your uh traffic
join pacman.com is the website better21
is the coupon code and i would love to
open some phone lines after don junior's
uh speech today okay
um other super chats coming in hermes
tres meste
megastas says david are you planning any
expansions to your garden in 2021 are
there going to be huge dumps of seeds in
david's 2021 garden
yeah i am planning on a garden expansion
i am actually working i recommend it to
you guys on a recent stream
the youtube channel epic gardening and a
bunch of you went and you found kevin
and people sent him messages he sent me
a message saying david i don't know what
you did on stream but
i'm getting massive dumps of messages
from your viewers
he is going to help me expand the garden
and he's looking really closely at
how i can get i might do some vertical
uh
some very interesting vertical um
planters
that you can kind of go up as the name
suggests and we're going to have a lot
of really really interesting things so
that is that is upcoming
very exciting um have i ever thought of
running for a political a local
political position do you find it better
to be a moderator of the chaos
yeah i i'm not that interested in in
running for local politics
no um it just doesn't appeal to me
just doesn't appeal i want to say thanks
to ceruse
fidgel or figgiel i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly
ceruse or cyrus but you are new member
number one at joinpakman.com and number
four
overall david wills wants to know what
are my top two favorite dumplings like
for example
stickers sao mai isn't it shumai
now i don't know that i consider a
samosa a dumpling
we might have to put that to a vote not
today because today's too important of a
day
i had samosas last week i don't i don't
know that i consider that a
that a dumpling it's delicious
but uh not sure about that i'd have to
think about that
will i discuss the garden expansion in
the boner show probably yeah
make a shirt saying bet's mail all right
i'll look into that anthony thank you
micah ortiz has just signed up at
joinpakman.com you are new member number
five today thanks mika
i appreciate that okay let's
look at some of the videos from earlier
today
uh let's look at let's look at some ted
cruz stuff from earlier today aaron
rupar from vox has been
all over this let's go to the ted cruz
elements there's matt gates don't care
about that right now
i specifically want to see ted cruz
i heard it was almost like he was having
a medical incident
but let's judge for ourselves
cpac no cruise where is cruz
oh here's the cruise material
all right let's start in chronological
order
uh okay here we go
god bless cpac
it's already weaponized
i gotta say orlando is
awesome
it's not as nice as cancun
that's republican humor guys that's
republican humor for you
but it's nice yeah he seems completely
shot out of a cannon
bernie is wearing mittens
and aoc is telling us she was murdered
wow wow
and the media desperately desperately
desperately wants to see
a republican civil war
bernie okay let's continue
by the way how many of you all have
eaten at a restaurant in the last six
months
can i just stop and say how strange
the rules are right now i want to
understand how this virus works so when
you walk in
you got to put your he's still trying to
understand how it works so you're into
this thing
your mask on sadly i've got two
you walk in you got to put your mask on
you sit down you take your mask off
see apparently the virus is actually
connected to elevation
wow this guy is really stupid really
really stupid and just a bad person
everybody can get immunized we can have
herd immunity everywhere
and we're going to wear masks for the
next 300 years
oh no you know the reason why see here's
the thing
let me talk a little bit about the whole
map do we really do we want to see we'll
go back to it okay we'll go back to it
let me talk a little bit about this mask
thing
so i've been seeing some really um
really conspiratorial copy pasta posted
by some people i went to high school
with on facebook and it's this stuff
about
why get vaccinated it's not a hundred
percent
you could still be carrying it you still
have to wear masks
things can't open why get vaccinated
right this is like the gist of the copy
pasta that they're sending around
the reason that epidemiologists and
immunologists and public health people
have to be so cautious and remind people
just because you got vaccinated doesn't
mean everything can open yet
it's because if they don't do this stuff
everybody will go and get
vaccinated and then 10 minutes later
they'll have a concert at their house or
whatever
when you actually have one-on-one
conversations with epidemiologists or
whatever
look at a recent interview with dr
ashish ja who said at a societal level
we're going to continue needing masks in
grocery stores and all you know we're
going to need all this stuff for some
time until we we actually really
vaccinate everybody
but you know let's let's be real here
vaccinated adults who work from home are
going to be at extremely low risk if you
get together and you're indoors
without masks but because there are so
many people who are looking
for anything oh five people got
vaccinated
open everything and i want i want to go
to a rave
now that's why it's because of people
like ted cruz
that we continue hearing airing on the
side of caution
anyway it's it's disappointing because
if everybody understood okay
if they got vaccinated and they work
from home
they might be able to say six of us are
going to get together indoors but
me unvaccinated with my 20 unvaccinated
friends we still shouldn't do it if it
weren't for that
yeah anyway all right let's move on
let's look at a couple other
ted cruz clips here we'll go over mask
stuff
i remember there were reports that riots
were going to come
into suburb mostly peaceful fiery but
mostly peaceful
there were reports riots were going to
come into the suburbs i got to tell you
in houston where i live
there weren't any rioters
because let's be very clear if there had
been
they would discover what the state of
texas thinks about the second amendment
right to keep and bear arms
wow it's just red meat to the dumbest of
the dumb of the right
in the immortal words of william wallace
freedom
he seems almost to be having a manic
episode really really strange
uh so that was ted cruz's speech earlier
today at cpac probably just a preview of
what we're expecting
um we're about 30-ish minutes from
kimberly guilfoyle
introducing donald trump jr thank you i
want to say to cayden nelson who just
signed up at joinpackman.com
also vitali podnos just signed up you
guys are new members
six and seven also five more people
signing up via twitch including zagheed
caspa hardlined and others
that is plus five putting us at 12
very much appreciate it and uh listen
i'm going to be really upfront with you
guys
the end of uh 2020
we had massive massive dumps of
memberships
um february is looking like it's going
to be our worst
month from the standpoint of memberships
net memberships meaning
subscriptions minus cancellations in
probably 14 or 15 months
it's just tough out there right now so i
would love it
i would love it and it'll help get the
phone lines open if you
grabbed a membership at joinpacman.com
let's go to a few other super chats here
let's see here samosas are more like
indian empanadas i agree i agree i don't
consider
a samosa under the umbrella of uh of
dumplings
nope not gonna catch me saying that
uh anthony wants me to make a beta male
t-shirt all right we'll see
super billy says get a good look at that
golden statue of trump at cpac i didn't
see it
i didn't see it david i bought 30 inch
tall raised garden beds from kevin at
epic gardening last year they're
fantastic highly recommend yeah i'm
looking at those pretty strongly myself
andrew says david how are you today well
let's see we are i got my second vaccine
dose today
i'm monitoring my fever with an infrared
thermometer i was at 97.7
about 20 minutes ago let's just see just
to keep everybody safe if i do
go above i will end the stream
uh 98 okay
it may be starting we went from 97 7 to
98
so that's that's a little that's a
little something
oh we'll keep an eye on that hopefully i
can't even get this thing turned off
oh my god it's just staying on all right
i guess it's just going to stay on for
now
anyway we're going to keep that going
we'll we'll keep an eye on that
otherwise doing very well drummer shy
says could this be trump's last cpac
before criminal charges
maybe maybe who knows jf says ted cruz
is trying to be ricky gervais and
failing yes ted cruz wears diapers that
i don't know anything about
steven says cruz stole amphetamines from
trump jr it appears
he seemed to be he seemed to be shot out
of a cannon david i would love to know
if you have any guilty pleasure on your
favorite ice cream flavor
um pistachios favorite ice cream flavor
i think my guilty pleasure is pistachio
ice cream
foxy dragon says cruz's speech actually
included the word fight
yeah that should have been uh exhibit a
in trump's impeachment trial
how much blood do you think will be in
don junior's cocaine system yeah we'll
see
favorite type of girl scout cookie i
believe it's the um
is it the samoan the one with the little
uh
the chocolate and the coconut bits i
think that's that one meow
very good my wife got moderna i got
pfizer we are interested to see how your
second ghost goes
does goes regarding side effects yes i
will have updates
soon ted cruz involved invoking william
wallace without realizing that wallace
would have deleted ted cruz
pantman says simply david cordy's board
says ted cruz should give up being a
failed politician and become a failed
comedian well said
very very well said this is rick scott
we're we're just waiting for the uh don
jr speech
most of this stuff is complete and total
trash
in a couple minutes maybe we'll listen
to like 60 seconds of rick scott i just
think this stuff is so worthless
my curiosity with don jr is just to take
the temperature of where the republican
crowd is on the trump family
and what don jr's continued position is
on the election is he going to focus in
on the election was stolen in this type
of thing
and then of course sunday if all goes
well i'll cover the trump speech where
he may announce a 2024 candidacy but
most of this stuff is
is bottom feeding trash of no no value
uh whatsoever okay
um did i find oh i did oh oh oh
i'm glad you brought this up so
i've been trying to shout out different
people
that are friends of the show who are
creators
okay last week i shouted out
kevin from epic gardening a lot of my
viewers
already know about kevin and then kevin
saw it
and he was appreciative and it was great
but now kevin has
it must be close to a million
subscribers at this point there was
another
creator that i was trying to remember
the name of last time
and i failed to remember we have the
opportunity here
to absolutely blow up the channel of a
new creator that i think
is fantastic this is a sort of a friend
acquaintance of mine
who does thai cooking videos on youtube
okay his channel is tune tune
channel only 276 subscribers
he makes primarily thai but also other
asian dishes
completely from scratch i'm talking
about
you make tom yum soup you don't buy
the tom yum seasoning you get the
lemongrass
you get the galangal or galangal i think
it is
uh you get the kefir lime leaves etc um
he is absolutely excellent so this is an
invitation
uh let's go to toontoon channel wow 10
people already subscribed just since i
mentioned it
we can make this youtube channel my
friends we can make this youtube channel
uh it is absolutely excellent and tell
them that david pakman show sent you
he will absolutely love it uh let's see
286 337. wow
we're we're doing it right now uh yeah
no this is the small creator that i
wanted to
shout out actually looks like he's
growing his own
kefir lime leaves which is amazing
this is like double triple everything is
from scratch
and just really really nicely nicely
done uh videos
so i would one of my favorites actually
is
where was it yeah the thai green curry
this is just fantastic we're getting in
so early with this channel that he's not
even monetized yet you don't even have
to sit through
oh hold on i'll paste the link i'm sorry
okay i'll paste the link in twitch you
don't even have to sit through ads
because he's not even monetized yet
so anyway this is a really good channel
to shout out
really really great stuff and if people
want one more
let's see 494 608 oh my god we might
even get him to a thousand subscribers
like right now
this is insane just one other one if
people want another recommendation this
is also a big time friend of the show
tyler florence wolf it down tyler
florence has a new podcast
his channel is still relatively small
only 7 000 subscribers
tyler of course from food network fame
big
big booster of progressive media
he does both a long form like sitting
around
talking podcast and he also does recipe
videos
he advised me on a number of different
recipe related
elements not long ago uh so this is
another really great channel so those
are two great channels
that i recommend people uh people
subscribe to
let's see how we're doing with
toontoon's channel
871 wow we just do you guys realize we
just
made this channel go go 4x where it was
five minutes ago that is insane
uh so anyway check that out very very
exciting and we are back to cpac
and standing by for kimberly guilfoyle
and don jr
coming up momentarily
what was the name of the thai cooking
channel okay it's
toontune channel t-h-u-n-t-h-u-n
channel and i pasted the link
a bunch of times all right this is
called the pacman
bump all right i'll paste the link a few
more times
pasting it in twitch and pasting it in
youtube excellent stuff oh
we're gonna get him to a thousand look
at this i just love this he's gonna have
no idea what's going on
989 let's see i hope he has
notifications turned on for every
subscriber
we did it ladies and gentlemen we got it
1001 1060.
this is the freaking best he paid
nothing he has no idea that this is even
going on he's just going to be shocked
1.11 oh my god this is awesome
anyway i'll let you guys know what the
uh what the reaction is eventually
okay sorry guys um i love doing this i
love doing this for uh for small
creators
let's get back to it uh sebastian says
the best is yet to come yes it is
david if you search twitter for golden
calf the first result should be the
video
of trump golden statue at cpac all right
let's check it out
golden calf oh this looks
crazy this looks crazy hold on a second
that is so cool
what a great event huh is it wearing
flip-flops it looks like it's wearing
flip-flops
so what you just saw there was a literal
golden idol a golden calf statue of
donald
represent i don't know who this guy is
but very very wild wild wild stuff
um okay do you guys want to uh to hear
from a new
a voicemail caller this is someone who
we've never heard from before
they are kooky but i will play it we can
maybe nickname them
i do want to thank brenda kitchner for
signing up at joinpackman.com
thanks to zoe mallett for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
bethany folks so the ladies are
representing today bethany folks is a
new member
casper hanek has signed up and
laura mckinney thanks to all five of you
for signing up at joinpackman.com
also via twitch 10 more people
including james hardline and astro lycos
gif with some gifts and others
very much appreciate that the coupon is
working on my website
it is working it's better 21. here's a
new voicemail caller okay
let's uh workshop some names for this uh
individual take a listen i'll tell you
one thing boy
trump is more man than you'll ever be
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
you are bought and paid for
joe [ __ ] biden
what do you guys think what do we what
do we need uh
what do we need as a nickname for that
gentleman
beer bq that's not bad
mic pillow oh man
now for people who think that's fake
this person has been emailing us
also for years if it's a joke it's like
a three-year joke
swole cheeto hmm
the wrestler
al-qaeda that's interesting
there is a kind of a wwe k fabe type
thing yeah there's a feel of that
stanza man what about what about
something and he he though the way he
delivers it is almost um
it's almost like a poetry in a sense i
wonder if we could call him the haiku
something
could that work the haiku uh
haiku hillbilly hillbilly haiku
something like that would it am you guys
with me here
let's listen to it once more
i'll tell you one thing boy trump
is more man than you'll ever be
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
you are bought and paid for
joe [ __ ] biden
i think that the haiku hillbilly there's
something
about his cadence i know it's not
actually a haiku but
there's something about that that i like
let's
let's sit on it and if we get another we
need a remix by the way if any of our if
any of our remixers are in the chat and
you want the original
on that one um ideally including some of
my commentary maybe even mentioning that
we might call him the haiku hillbilly
i can get that to you just email in
through my website contact form
i think that there could be some really
good really really good remixes there
big thank you to araceli ramos wow
the ladies are crushing the membership
drive today i think like
80 percent of new members today are
women which is notable because shows
like mine
have a 75 male audience as a general
thing
um so that is that is extraordinary
welcome to everybody all are welcome of
course uh let's look at a few other
super chats here
um okay where did i leave off
edward says i got the same vaccine a few
weeks ago after my second shot i was out
of commission almost didn't get out of
bed
fever headache sour stomach all day hope
you don't get it as bad i hope not
can we get your take on biden's first
bombing and removal of 15 minimum wage
from the stimulus package yeah
so on monday i've already i've already
got it we finished today's show already
so monday i will be covering
biden does his first bombing while
backing off of
15 minimum wage it's extraordinarily
distressing
and you know all last week was people
saying david
you won't talk about andrew cuomo
because he's a democrat and you're a
democrat and i said i'm not a democrat
and i did talk about it and
we said let the cards fall where they
may the allegations are very serious
joe biden does something good i'll tell
you if joe biden does something bad i'll
tell you
i don't care about these people as
people i care about them as
elected officials who should be doing
things for us oh people are saying that
things are going
crazy on the toontoon train
1.5 wow that is amazing so if you're
just joining us
i shouted out uh a sort of friend
acquaintance
uh who has a youtube channel with thai
cooking when he was at 276 subscribers
about 15 minutes ago
we've gotten him to 1500 subscribers
this is just
awesome absolutely awesome if you want
to join in it's the toontoon
channel you should be able to find it i
can only
imagine his confusion the next time he
looks at his youtube channel he's like
where
how did i get 1300 more subscribers in
like
15 minutes i love it
i love it there's 1.5 awesome thanks
guys appreciate that
um okay
ellis says rick scott committed the
largest medicare fraud
in the u.s if not the largest close to
it rick scott looks like a bond henchman
who apologizes to james before
fail failing to torture him to death
much like
he did to medicare patients in florida
yes pantman says super speed or flight
if you had to choose
super speed like running now i mean i
can't imagine that'd be good for your
knees
i would take i would take flight the
ability for flight i think
super speed running sounds like it'd be
bad for my knees
david if you search twitter for golden
okay yeah we saw the video
we saw the video
uh now i missed a few hold on
the best is yet to come right the bot
squad stands with toontoon david thank
you
hubs husband's second vaccine week ago
temperature 101 just temporary of course
of course why won't biden call uyghur
prosecution a genocide
persecution of genocide don't know you
should be asked
thanks david for awesome coverage my
wife and i watch your show very often
thank you and the republican party has
officially gone from avowed christians
to confirmed pagans
haiku klux klan oh that's not bad
the two names for that caller i think
the top candidates right now are the
haiku hillbilly
or high ku klux klan i like both
maybe we'll put it to a vote i hope you
don't develop a fever
when kimberly guilfoyle starts speaking
i know i mean look this is this is what
we have to look forward to
ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for freedom
and liberty and the american dream the
best
is yet to come right
i actually have a song parody related to
that
where was that
kimberly guilfoyle oh here it is
yeah this one's from our friend brian
crawford this is a good one
this is what we have to look forward to
i love this ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american
the dream is yet to come
stand back and stand by
stand back and stand by is what makes it
stand back and stand by is just
perfect perfect um
oh i'm told that the toontoon channel is
about to hit 2000 no it's still far it's
at 1.73 still got a little ways to go
but that's great yeah it's blowing up
totally blowing up all right um let's
pull up the schedule i believe this is
the last thing
before the bedlam that will be
kimberly guilfoyle and don jr here's the
schedule
let's see so we're past the jewish
prayer service let me see here
3 27 so oh
this was supposed to be over already so
it looks like they're running maybe 15
minutes behind we're still
going to hear from josh hawley and then
donald trump jr will reignite the spirit
of the american dream
all right so we're standing by for that
it shouldn't be much longer let's just
take a quick listen to what rick scott
is saying to fail
even more spectacularly in today's
fast-moving world
than it has in the past that is what i'm
going to fight for
that is one i'm asking you to fight for
our battle to win the future is he
normally this mushmouth
in washington they're doing the opposite
looking backward and forming a circular
firing squad
they're busy assigning blame and
avoiding responsibility
you and i don't have the time to waste
going backwards
the people in washington have that
covered
all we've got is us the power of our
ideals
and the truth and that is plenty
now it's time to get to work making this
great country
better than it has ever been thank you
god bless you and god bless this great
nation
have a great day all right so josh
hawley is supposed to be next
so we're going to keep an eye on that
it's josh hawley
one of the most horrible senators out
there and then
it will be uh don jr
sort of reminded me rick scott there of
the entire god bless
the united sheish incident that trump
was involved in
which i can't even i'm having trouble
finding now but that's okay not
important
here's josh hawley he's a horrible
person um
i want to say thanks to jeff in boston
for gifting five
twitch subs and more generally to the
six new subscribers via twitch which
puts us
at 34. i also want to say thank you to
two really special people
emma grinnell and stina bennett
emma and stina have signed up at
joinpakman.com
the boys are getting dominated somehow
we have a 75
male audience and 85 of today's new
members on my
my website are women i mean it's i don't
know
i don't know the math of it is just
crazy but welcome
welcome welcome welcome we're just um
standing by for a kimberly guilfoyle
and don jr when kimberly guilfoyle said
the best is yet to come she didn't know
she was predicting biden's win yeah well
said
danny thompson oh sorry danny where'd
your message go
that caller sounds like foghorn leghorn
from looney tunes haiku hillbilly is
good
how about deliverance dave referencing
the movie of course that's another
possibility
how about the right to haiku
not bad do you do shout outs for small
creators regularly
um i don't know not reg if i have
something compelling to shout out
someone else said haiku hogan it's the
best of both worlds
someone said mark twang that's not bad
mark twain mark twang
i like that for me right now the top
names for that caller
are haiku hillbilly um
mark twang is good and then wait what
was the other one that had haiku in it
now i forgot what was the other one we
liked haiku hillbilly mark twang
there was a third one
it's like gone i have no memory of it
could be the vaccine kicking in
hi ku klux klan how c i'm just going to
make a note of these so i don't forget
haiku klux klan
haiku hillbilly
and mark twang mark twang is pretty good
mark twang is pretty good
steve says the limer limer hick
david have you ever seen ted cruz do
simpson's impressions no
i don't think i could stand the cringe
i'd probably have to stop streaming
kylie says g'day from australia good day
kylie
welcome nick says gomer defile for the
voicemail gomer to file stop that
david no kkk because of a youtube ai
word flag
fair that that may be a reason to stay
away from that josh hawley goes first so
they're sure the nazi commentators are
unmuted for junior
yikes they're really bringing on josh
hawley as a missourian i'm disgusted
with him and many here are still trying
to get him to resign i don't think he's
going to resign
corey says no grifters only gifters
absolutely absolutely
james says a haiku trump has so much
wealth
better and best cash urine golden
son of fraud nice
nicely done edgar allen bro that's not
bad
i don't think it's i don't think it's
relevant to that particular caller
uh but i like it i like edgar allen bro
will i discuss the wave of voter
suppression laws in republican
legislatures
yes yes i'm told to double check the
toontoon channel
yes we are at 1.82 guys let's get him to
2000.
this is a this is just a friend who
doesn't even know i'm doing this he has
a great
thai cooking youtube channel um
oh don't tell me this is him saying what
the hell is going on no it's not
uh we are he started at 200 subs on
youtube
about 20 minutes ago we are very close
to getting him to 2000
subscribers i imagine that he's like
napping or at work
and he's going to get up and all of a
sudden have 2 000 subscribers on youtube
1.83 there we go it's going really well
really really well let's listen to a few
minutes of josh hawley
experience with this unfortunately you
know on january the 6th
i objected during the electoral college
certification maybe you heard about it
yeah i did and what did that lead to
if we were wondering where the crowd was
at on trumpian conspiracies
it's giving a standing ovation to
someone who objected to the results
that's where
we now know where they're at and i said
i
said we ought to have a debate about
election integrity
i said it is the right of the people to
be heard and my constituents in missouri
want to be heard on this issue and so i
did what by the way
i did what our democrat friends my
democrat colleagues have done
in every single election where
republican president
has won for the last 20 years do you
know they've objected to 11
different states this is maybe one of
the worst people currently uh
currently in the senate okay um
let's see what else we've got coming in
here steven robbins
says gonna need a binder for all these
women david p.s
another legendary hair day my guy yeah
yeah yeah it's uh
i have to tell you i i have a
dermatology appointment not that long
from now i'm a little worried about some
of these elements
like i don't has this always been my
hairline
i look at pictures and it sort of looks
like it it has
but i'm definitely gonna have to ask
about it i'm getting a little bit
worried about it just a little little
bit
we're gonna find out and i'll report
back i'm told that the toontoon channel
has surpassed 2
000 subscribers and it has it is now at
2.07
wow isn't that just the best
that is just unbelievable unbelievable
okay a tnav says david did you see the
cpap crowd boo
organizers asking them to wear a mask no
let's look for that um let's see here
cpac booze
how do you spell booze is it b-o-o-e-s
b-o-e-s booze masks
let's just say just say masks
b-o-o-s oh here we go does the bill of
rights matter
the first amendment it matters we
conservatives believe in the rule of law
because we know that when the law is
enforced our rights are protected
that's why we're doing such a a big
effort at this seat back to talk about
the bill of rights
but i also want to mention one thing and
i know this might sound like a little
bit of a downer
but we also believe in property rights
and this is a private hotel
and we believe in the rule of law so we
need to comply with the laws of this
county that we're in but a private hotel
just like your house gets to set its own
rules
carly our cpac director
well as dan mentioned we are in a
private facility
um and we do want to be respectful of
the
um ordinances that they have as their
private property so please
everyone when you're in the ballroom
when you're seated you should still be
wearing a mask
so if everybody can go ahead work on
that
work on it i know i know it's it's not
the most fun
you have the right
this tells you whoa that tells you just
about everything you need to know
about uh about these people all right
hey guys listen
listen to this you guys have to listen
to this
so uh
johnny who runs the toontoon channel
he just texted my girlfriend and he says
i'm at work
my phone is going crazy with youtube
notifications
saying david pakman sent them is that
true
is this legit so many of you signed up
to this channel
that johnny who runs it thinks that we
it's almost like he thinks that they're
bots coming in
because so many he had 200 subscribers
half an hour ago
and now he has 2170 isn't that
unbelievable and
his phone is going crazy he does have
notifications turned on where he gets a
ping for everybody that subscribes
he has 2 000 notifications that he has
to clear now
can you imagine okay all right we're
getting ready we're getting wound up
here for kimberly guilfoyle
and uh and don jr a few other people i
want to thank
tati are people kidding and just signing
up with women's names just to mess with
me
new member tatiana leverton has signed
up
val ferrante and derek moore okay very
good
thanks guys appreciate that thank you
very much
um and also a big shout out to hedy gg
theo rex duncan disorderly as well um
three additional via twitch
which we love we love twitch uh what's
the my do i have a live twitch counter i
do
um oh that's youtube sorry
yeah here's a twitch live subscriber
counter you know actually this youtube
number is not right
i think we're only about 100 away from
1.3 million it only updates every 10
000.
yeah we're only 280 youtube subs away
from this rolling all the way over to
1.3 million
which is how far beyond a million is
that one point three
minus one million one minus one zero
three one zero zero
three hundred thousand three hundred
thousand divided by a million
three into ten three three that's thirty
percent past
one million that's crazy
that is nuts all right other super chats
coming in
pacman for life thank you david gonna
need a binder for all these oh
steven sent that twice appreciate that
mama atheist
says where did mama atheist go small
creator here i'm a climate scientist
regardless of my name most of my content
revolves around science very good
adam says open the phone lines if we get
toon tuned to 2000 subs
no i don't think so maddie says i hereby
declare the department of common sense
be created i'll be the sole ranking
member
my purpose will be to slap any
politician across the head if they dare
vote against
basis human rights aiden says anyone
else thinks seth meyers should be
playing josh hawley on snl yeah that's
that's actually good
that's a good idea um
oh my god hold on i think there's
another toontoon message
he's loving it he's loving it he's
absolutely loving it
okay um let's see where
let's see where things are at 2.36 wow
i mean honestly it looks like 3 000 subs
is on the table for toontoon
it's unbelievable really unbelievable
okay it's gonna go david accept it
it's gonna go david accept it i don't
know what that means i almost forgot how
disturbing it is to hear a crowd of
people cheering on such bs well
you might want to not watch on sunday
then when trump speaks
i have the same hair issue plus graying
oh i think cash only was saying accept
that i am losing my hair
i i don't think it's clear that i am
i mean everybody else tells me i'm
clearly not i think i'm just paranoid
about it
yeah okay
carlos says i started a channel about
finance can i get a shout out yeah i
can't shout everybody
i mean i have to be real you know we're
shouting out like one channel per uh
one channel per um stream okay
mini painting studio says on a scale of
one to super villain what's your take on
trump wearing an extra wide
husky size red tie today i don't know
anything about that
david i'll subscribe to your guys but we
should raid the tabernacle
upcoming lefty stuck at 25k okay i don't
know anything about that i'd have to
investigate it first
casey bates says you have the best math
tremendous numbers
did ted cruz bust into don jr's secret
stash before coming on stage yeah many
people wondering that
someone should put bongos and finger
snaps under the haiku hillbilly
make it sound like a pottery slam fellow
bostonian as a sustainability analysis i
can confirm
no matter what republicans say
communities and private players
want green infrastructure yes
is josh hawley pronounced like trump
says fraud josh hawley
that's a good question ian says
raid paid vacation on instagram we don't
raid i
have no way to rate instagram i've never
heard of that
daniel says hearing many financial
institutions we're betting against
toontoon don't be surprised if youtube
freezes subs
yeah uh from what i read there were
major
major financial institutions shorting
subs on toontoon
they saw toontoon was at 276 earlier
today
and they said this is going to zero i
looked at it and i said
i like the stock so i'm long on toontoon
and anybody who had shorted this
including large institutions
uh they are they have just lost
10x toontoon exploding from 276
to 2440. unbelievable
unbelievable and i'm telling you just
hold i would just hold and wait
i'm expecting big big things
jake says my friend thinks you're a
capricorn but i think you're an aquarius
are
we right i couldn't care less about
astrology
but i am an aquarius i i do i couldn't
tell you what that means
i think it's bs i think it's laughable
nothing but i am aquarius
matthew says sorry david can't watch the
show anymore i've got toontoon stuff to
do now
yes exactly toontoon taking the world by
storm
2.47 000 subscribers
an amazing amazing could i get a live
count hold on a second let me see if i
can get a live count
on toontoon
live subscriber count
let's see what happens here oh stand by
for this
this was where we started boom
can you imagine
isn't that something
wow wow
yeah okay it seems not to update
instantly oh there it goes again oh my
god 2500.
look at that 247
man i love it i absolutely love it
we're holding the line on toontoon no
sales
oh my god ainsley's bible study did you
see that
ainsley's bible study is that a segment
on fox news that's
nuts all right we're standing by now for
uh
we're standing by for kimberly guilfoyle
and don jr okay
dom says david i share your paranoia
about losing my hair but i think i'm
good i just have a five head
okay well what about me jordan says
david my girlfriend won't take the
vaccine how should i educate her on the
vaccine
seems a lot of people of color are
afraid of getting the vaccine
you'd have to figure out what exactly
her opposition is and then go from there
some people have put a limit sale limit
sale on toontoon they like it
they like toontoon at 10k
uh i may actually start
i i'm i'm long on margin with toontoon
2610. look at that that is
that is powerful guys
that is just in a matter of seconds
unbelievable
unbelievable oh what is this listen to
this is
genki fuji i am a japanese journalist
and an author of more than 70 books on
international relations i run online
world forecast news service i respect
president trump and american
conservatives president trump
fought against chinese communists in
order to protect
the entire free world president trump
he's a real american samurai i want to
make
us japan alliance stronger i want to
build
solid friendship with real american
patriots
or american samurai these are cpac
advertisers
it's it's giga cringe yeah i want to say
thanks to
danielle chevak danielle has just signed
up at
joinpakman.com the phone lines will open
at 100. get those memberships at
joinpakman.com i believe this is today's
keynote introduction presuming we will
hear from kimberly guilfoyle
depending on how bad her speech is we
may go to toontoon instead alright here
we go
all right all right well hello cpac how
we doing florida
how are we doing america
i have to tell you i absolutely love the
state of florida i mean really what's
not to love compared to
california and new york right
i love this state i love governor
desantis and
we all love all of you and thank you for
being here today and standing for
conservative values and principles
okay now in the great state of florida
it's not all sunshine and rainbows
well not every day maybe like six out of
seven uh because
i gotta remind you of one thing that joe
biden i cannot believe it still
is in the white house believe it sister
but joe did not disappoint because just
like we told you
he is leading from behind
from behind kamala that is
however with joe biden sort of bumbling
his way through the first month the
reporters probably in the back of the
room are trying desperately to write our
obituary but she steals that back of the
room thing from trump
in this country this is perverse
the press wants you to believe that the
american conservative movement
is fractured they want america to
believe that this
movement is dead news flash
to those out there we aren't going
anywhere okay
it's the thousands of conservatives here
today and the millions across
this country who are not going to be
silenced and we are definitely not going
to cede
this fight to this no one's trying to
silence the communists
who want to see our nation burn
the fight for liberty the fight for
conservative values
and the fight for the heart and soul of
this nation
will not be abandoned
okay that fight continues right here
and right now with all of us i wish she
listed the communists
policies and programs we're not going
anywhere
this movement is not going anywhere and
i can promise you this
president trump is not going anywhere
okay so that's a signal about what we
might hear on sunday from trump
that's the good news
we love president trump and i'll tell
you i will confidently say that
president trump from his desk at
mar-a-lago will accomplish more for
america
in the next four years than joe biden
and kamala harris could ever
dream of really
his desk i like that that is because we
are not giving up
the republican party is being reborn
thanks to president trump
it is being reborn as a party of the
working class
of minorities of hard-working american
men
and women party of minorities america
first
the party of president trump
and we bid a farewell to the weak need
the spineless and the cowards
that are posing in dc pretending that
they're working for the people
okay let's send them
a pink slip straight from cpac what do
you say
four years from now you mean
we tell them that america has no use for
them and this movement
is leaving those cowards in the ash bin
of history and we will strive forward
thanks to the courage
the policies and the strength of
president trump
he's not president what is she talking
about the policies
instead we will chart a new path a path
driven by bold conservative solutions
a path where we don't couch out to the
demands of the leftist mob
and a path where we are willing to stand
up and fight
for what we believe in and what we hold
true they're completely out of power
california to new york
we will fight to take back this country
however to do so we must do three
important things
we must demand more from our elected
leaders and officials
and those that are actually pursuing
public office
it is not enough to just be quote
republican
that means very little when they get to
washington dc
and they don't perform we're not
interested in those type of politician
empty suits we want fighters like
president trump
warriors for this country for america i
thought you weren't supposed to use the
word fight anymore
and our movement must stay true to
america first as the democrats scurry to
re-enter the corrupt iran nuclear deal
and cozy up to china
we must understand that the survival of
our nation
is based on putting the american worker
and the american
family first and finally we must take
our message into every corner of our
nation
america first means all of americans
all of us united together as a country
our ideas our conservative values and
the solutions that we
champion are the key to lifting up
everyone in this country
as a movement our message must transcend
party lines socioeconomic lines and
cultural
lines as one america we put first
if we can accomplish that over the next
four years i can
promise you we will be winning elections
it will only be the start of what is
going to happen because why did they
just lose everything then
the best is yet to come
god bless cpac god bless madam mercedes
slap and the entire team
your family the military the veterans
law enforcement first
bettermans god bless president trump and
thank
you president trump on behalf of a
grateful and humble
nation god bless this country and ladies
and gentlemen it gives me great pleasure
to introduce to you the son of the
greatest president this country has seen
a leader of the warrior movement and
conservative values
donald trump juniors
it's funny how like her whole thing it's
almost like someone else has been in
power for the last four years rather
than like
they were in power for four years lost
everything and biden's been in for a
month now
she's acting like they got to get power
back they've been out of power for years
and years
they've been out of power 35 days
thanks diane and jason for the
memberships
how's it going cpac oh god he's
screaming
or i heard someone earlier phrase it a
little bit better
tpack so what it feels like guys
well first and foremost it's awesome to
be here it's great to see this kind of
enthusiasm and it's great to actually be
in a full room
uh passing kovacs guys what i see
in florida right now is exemplary of the
republican party
right this is the state like the party
is
that has open schools
open businesses and open churches
what we've seen in some of the more
left-leaning states
is exactly the opposite the only thing
that they have open
is open borders
and it doesn't work guys in the first
thing
most states do have open borders between
each other that's in the constitution
things that i said would come true in
the book liberal privilege that i wrote
last summer
are happening we listen to months of
media telling us that joe biden
he's a moderate don't worry
he's not going to end energy
he's not going to end pipelines which is
partially correct he's not going to end
russian pipelines he's only going to end
american pipelines this is stupid these
are just
fine they're going to cave to china no
that was never gonna happen
of course it happened you think that
billion dollar investment in hunter came
for free no the chinese
the chinese have a great return on
investment
but guys more importantly
this may be even dumber than trump's own
speeches who would have thought that
within 33 days we'd be bombing the
middle east again
i would have oh no guys come on the
military industrial complex i'm
surprised nobody in the room booze
because they love bombing
i guess they waited till the first month
so they couldn't say that was part of
the first 30 but
it was only shortly thereafter where we
started bombing
the middle east
speaking of bombing the middle east have
you seen liz cheney's poll numbers
oh people want captions
oh listen the one thing i'll say for liz
cheney is
i'm sure she has a lot of bipartisan
support because if there's one thing
that she and joe biden definitely want
to do it's bomb
the middle east everything else is a
disaster
everything else is just rhino policies
the kinds of policies
that put the republican party in a
position where they needed a donald
trump
hmm no seriously
liz cheney and her politics are only
slightly less
popular than her father is at a quail
hunt
okay what
fact checkers fact checkers
please have at it this is cringy
he is bombing it's weird
fact check true right
listen like i said liz cheney she hates
donald trump and his policies
because her family has a long history of
friendly fire
but she also hates them because she's
tied to an establishment that has done
nothing but fail
us time and time again you've heard the
rhetoric from some of them over the last
couple weeks and now you've seen that
change very quickly
it's interesting that the first keynote
is really it's like attacking
republicans as much as it is democrats
last few decades is snatching defeat
from the jaws
of victory they've caved to every
special interest they've caved to
corporate america they've caved and
bowed
to the radical left that hates their
guts hates their values and hates their
freedoms
lincoln project liz as i'd like to call
her
is the leader of that failed movement
and if we want to go back to losing
if we want to go back to an america last
policy
we should be following that but i don't
and i don't think
anyone in this room does either
so you know what guys the first 30 days
has been a disaster
the lies the media told you wouldn't
happen
are all happening but hey at least they
have a diverse cabinet
what's he talking about right
really quiet in there it's very diverse
that's what we saw right
what is the policy of the sba well first
and foremost
we appointed a woman well that's
wonderful is she competent
because there's competent women and
there's incompetent women just like
there's competent men and incompetent
men
this is a weird dude guys it's a weird
guy
but when you don't have policy to
address
the incompetence and think you can get
away with it
by just talking about diversity blindly
it's sort of a problem isn't it
this month this month alone
they've banned the muppets
right i mean if there's things that you
thought were sort of
above cancellation you would be wrong
there is nothing the radical left won't
cancel
hasbro now wants a gender neutral mr
potato head
these are the issues of our times folks
i mean if hasbro really wanted a
gender-neutral mr potato head so badly
they should just slap a picture of cnn's
brian slettler
it's that this brian brian stelter
what did he call him slettler what
they don't call him mr potato head for
nothing i mean you know
we might as well get something out of
the branding
but guys we can sleddler all of these
things we can talk about the liberal
hypocrisy liberal privilege
just look at how magically
in 33 days children in cages
turned into migrant shelters
for children now
mind you that's a fair critique truly
changed if you look at the pictures
there's nice bars on the walls
nothing changed other than the media's
outlook where is the outrage
about this where is the outrage about an
asinine
immigration policy that is encouraging
people to bring children unaccompanied
and otherwise
into a country guess who gets hurt our
low-wage earners who for the first time
in modern history under donald trump
started seeing real wage growth
most people aren't clapping it's very
interesting
we see it time and time again there's a
double standard by which we live but
when you look at what's going on if
people were informed of the actual facts
rather than spoon fed and narrative by
big tech and the mainstream media
we wouldn't be in these things there was
a poll that came out just this week that
said one in six
people would not have voted for biden
had they known
about the hunter biden scandal
where is hunter
guys i'm sure he's making billions in
china right now don't worry
don't worry
one in six guys 17 of the 80 million
that voted for joe biden
wouldn't had they even heard of the
basics of his corruption
we were all talking about it guys after
this uh he's going to be playing
minesweeper on hunter's laptop just as a
just as a show of force andrew cuomo
sentencing nana to death for 10
months but no one was going to talk
about it
until they got their wishes no one was
going to address
democrat incompetence
we believe all women until they accuse a
democrat
then not so much
but guys that's why we have to stay
engaged that's why we
have to stay in the fight that's why we
can't allow them to steamroll
us like they have done for decades
when you look at what's going on just
this week in congress
you have democrats petitioning
major corporations comcast amazon
to ban conservative news outlets
not radical parties fox news
newsmax oan just ban them
you don't see republicans saying let's
talk about cnn as a
place of disinformation i mean as a
recipient of their ire for
a couple of years i can assure you that
they were lying about russia collusion
we all know that now but no one actually
brings it up
because they can get away with it what's
he talking about they are able to do
that
big tech will silence you if you come
out against it
they will crush you they will call you
racist and everything else just like
imagine we'll bring back cuomo right
imagine ron desantis did what cuomo has
done over the last couple years
he wouldn't be getting an emmy he'd be
in jail
right credible accusations of harassment
swept under the rug
verbal harassment swept under the rug
hiding evidence from the doj swept under
the rug no problem give him an emmy
remember fredo when he was talking about
it all for months oh
where's fredo he's so quiet these days
why isn't fredo talking about these
things right now
again liberal brothers didn't know we
can't address that really you can't
address that but you had no problem
joking around with massive q-tips
making clowns of yourselves for months
prior
that's what we're up against folks but
together
i don't understand what he's claiming to
be up against i don't get it
we can't be put in the corner we must be
out
and engaged and that's where you guys
come in
so i'm looking forward to sunday
i imagine
i imagine it will not be what we call a
low energy speech
and i assure you that it will solidify
donald trump and all of your feelings
about the maga movement as the future of
the republican party
so thank you cpac thank you for being
here does that mean trump's running
you guys are the best
so there's donald trump jr with an
aimless and meandering speech
spending probably about 35 or 40 percent
of the speech attacking republicans that
he believes
have the wrong opinions seemingly
indicating they're not really welcome
within the
magnified um
republican party the trumpified
republican party so that that's very
interesting
and then of course referring to trump's
speech scheduled for
uh roughly around this same time on
sunday which i plan to cover
the rumor is donald trump may announce
his 2024 candidacy we don't know
we don't know uh but that is uh
that is the the situation as far as we
know it and then make money do the
formula of life
then i'll just fall to ashes to have
that
with that lifted off of my soul
is i've never felt happier when i'm
coming
and and explaining what google was doing
this is an act of atonement to make my
conscious clear
the commercials are basically the best
thing the commercials are far
far better than uh than the actual
content
i want to say a big thank you to ronnie
lopez very much appreciate your support
also diane watson and jason atwood
thank you so very very much um it
appears as though that is the end for
today maybe maybe not in any case it's
going to be the end of my coverage
i will see everybody back here sunday
for the end of cpac with the trump
speech
no more young pharaoh after the
anti-semitic
comments it is high-level cringe as
goldie fawn
is pointing out i'll see everybody on
sunday